c'était une audition très attendue celle
du professeur out devant la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale le
directeur de lee a chu de marseille est
revenu sur la gestion du coc vide par le
gouvernement et par le corps
scientifique français le retour sur les
premières prises en charge sans oublier
bien sûr d'évoquer quelques chiffres une
audition qui n'aura pas manqué de
susciter l'intérêt de certains
détracteurs du professeur raoul tu as
commencé par martin hirsch le directeur
général de l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris qui accuse le
professeur à ou de faux témoignages dans
un courrier adressé au président de
l'assemblée nationale
ces déclarations qui mettent gravement
en cause l'ap-hp faites sous serment me
semble s'apparenter à un faux témoignage
en cause deux passages de l'audition de
didier rahout par la commission denquête
le 24 juin dernier
le premier est celui d'une estimation
des taux de décès en réanimation
un chiffre avancé par le professeur
marseillais est très vite contesté par
martin hirsch la mortalité dans la
réanimation ici dans ce travail toujours
et de 43% chez nous elle est de 16%
nous n'avons aucune donnée qui place à
43 % la mortalité dans les réanimations
de l'ap-hp voilà ce chiffre semble
renvoyer des résultats du registre
réseau européen de recherche en
ventilation artificielle
figurant dans un rapport de la cellule
de crise de l'ap-hp du 14 avril dernier
il ya plus de deux mois et demi donc à
ce moment là alors que la france était
en plein pic de l'épidémie
cette même instance évaluer le
pourcentage de décès en réanimation à
43% à l'ap-hp contre 41 % hors ap-hp
chiffre confirmé également par le
professeur eric comme chef de service à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris chez le confrère de lci pour paris
je confirme c'est effectivement pour les
malades en réanimation
je confirme c'est l'ordre de 40%
malheureusement autre passage de didier
rahout remis en question par martin
hirsch celui sur un patient chinois de
81 ans hospitalisé à paris fin janvier
est décédé ni février il y a
monsieur chinois qu'avec 80 ans qui
venait de la zone dubai pas de l'uad
d'accord qui s'est présentée à la pitié
salpêtrière
il y avait de la fièvre à 80 ans il
revenait de chine il n'a pas été testé
parce que santé publique a aidé il faut
tester que les gens de luan qui ont de
la fièvre et la toux
il est entré chez lui et on fait du sept
jours après après avoir contaminé sa
fille et lévis mourir d'un hôpital dans
lequel on lui redonne du remdh et si des
informations formellement démenties par
martin hirsch qui affirme que
l'octogénaire n'aurait jamais été
renvoyé chez lui par les hôpitaux
parisiens
et pourtant une déclaration du 29
janvier du professeur yazdan yazdanpanah
vient contredire ses déclarations il ya
un premier appel samu puis la pitié qui
n'ont pas retenu le cas deuxième appel
bichat paris samu bichat on n'a pas
retenu le cas le professeur raoul te
pointes donc les carences du processus
d'admission à l'hôpital qui se faisait
sans test mais à partir de critères qui
aurait rapidement démontré leurs limites
parole contre parole l'affairé holt est
décidément loin d'être terminée